i think you have one of the most
original comedic voices that i've
encountered there's no one else like you
and you would come on our show and you
would do stuff that i hadn't seen
anybody do
well i didn't see anybody do anything
like it on other late night spots and i
thought this is a real find this
this tig no taro i mean it was a joy it
was a joy to discover you and have you
come on the show
well i appreciate that the feeling is
mutual
and um and what was exciting for me
was um for you i mean
this wasn't the exciting part but for
years i was
turned down for talk shows and late
night or i'd have you know one shot or
no shot and
and i would get feedback that my
delivery was too slow or
too not enough jokes per minute i heard
um and uh too low-key
not mainstream enough and then when i
got a shot to come on your show
i remember leaving
the studio and i got a call from my
manager
saying that um that
your show had called to have me booked
again
immediately yes and that you wanted me
to be a regular on the show and i
i was i couldn't even comprehend that
because of all of the rejection i had
gotten and i feel like your show
gave me this incredible opportunity
to be myself to try out weird things and
it also
i'm certain um went hand in hand with
me being welcomed onto so many other
talk shows and um well i mean what i
remember is you came on your first show
you did some really unique impressions
that were really funny and we said oh
god she's really great
let's have her come back you came back
now most people in that situation would
say
i've got to be conservative i'm getting
my second shot i've got to make sure
it's safe
on your second shot for most of your
shot
for most of your act you slowly pushed a
stool
across the stage which was the gutsiest
thing
anybody would try even if it was your
15th time on the show
you might maybe you'd try it but it
would still feel risky
it was your second time on the show and
it was hilarious but
it was a stool bigger than this it was a
stool bigger than that and you remember
this andy and
take made a horrible noise which was the
point yeah it was the point
and you were pushing it around and
that was if someone had pitched that to
me i would have said
there's no way that's going to work
fortunately they didn't
you just did it well when i pitched it
um
to your producer probably jp buck
yeah exactly who jp um
he was like all right i trust you
i just let's let's see it and so he did
come down and
watch me do it i think at the comedy
store yeah and uh
and to be fair it doesn't work for a
long time
there's there is a long stretch there's
a long stretch where it's not working it
doesn't work and you have to commit to
it well also a shout out to jp buck who
does a beautiful job of
finding amazing people like you and uh
and and just making our enriching our
show
so conan i'll have you know i've been in
toronto for four weeks filming star trek
and was then in new york
uh for the tribeca film festival i flew
home
just to do this episode to say my
farewells and my thank yous to you
because i have to go back to tribeca
after i do this that's crazy you flew
i'm told yeah you you were saying you
i got on the first flight this morning
and you flew here
went right to your house took a shower
my sons who i hadn't seen
at this point in five weeks said look
how big we got
how cute and sad at the same time i
hugged them
kissed them and uh and yeah after i took
a shower ran out the door
and came to largo so you're a terrible
parent is what you're saying i am
i'm i i choose you over my adorable
precious children what i do with my kids
whenever they said daddy daddy we love
you
as i put my hands over their faces and
push them away and say
show business first that's what i do
that's how they've grown up and they
understand now
i understand did you miss the
andy you've seen it right i've seen it
i've seen it
it's a good bit it's a good bit it's not
a bit
well it's getting hard now because my
son is like six two so i have to like
yeah he's right up here when i'm an old
man and they're like we love you daddy
you're leaving this earth oh my god
speaking of show business first speaking
of old man
yeah my children
are deathly afraid of becoming old men
like they start to cry they'll ask how
old are they
they'll be five in two weeks and they
and they say
out of nowhere am i going to be an old
man
oh no and we say well you know what do
you think an old man
is and and they're like i don't know
just and then they
imitate an old man and it is their worst
nightmare they cry like tears in their
eyes and it comes up
i mean near daily am i going to be an
old man
and what's crazy is stephanie's father
moved in with us and we asked
you know his po his name is papa grande
yeah it's his god-given name and we say
and his rapper name yeah we say is papa
grande
an old man and they say no and we're
like
yeah yeah so where do they get this
news flash oh yeah but i mean we don't
know what an
old man we don't know what happened
they're both terrified
that's so funny you've got to start
telling them from what i can tell being
an old man is fantastic
yeah because you get to say whatever you
want you get to be a complete pain in
the ass
and you can probably eat ice cream all
day i mean i even went to the point of
asking
am i an old man because we're trying to
understand and they're like
no right but we know they saw something
somewhere they saw an old man old man
definitely made a bad impression on him
yeah
but stephanie's father is not an old man
okay well
it may be that they just got out of the
phase of
pooping themselves and not being able to
walk very well and they don't want to go
back there any time soon
that's true you know how the end of life
in the beginning of life are very
similar
yeah diapers and all that yeah that
could be okay
they're just you know trying not to bend
and butt benjamin button it they're
always saying i just want to be a kid
forever
and they they love candy and toys
they're the most generic
children yeah
[Laughter]
that's all your complaint is they're
generic
they're so adorable but they are so
terrified to be old men